foreign
[Music]
it's parody week you can find today's
track and all of our greatest hits from
over the years by subscribing to the
podcast on Spotify Apple Android and all
other major platforms before they ban us
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
don't bother trying to explain it to me
I know exactly what goes
[Music]
questions
you understand what no comments mean
just in case you claimed the song's
misinformation here's a pic of the
marriage certificate yeah no one ever
asked and you will never tell we know
the truth is that you honeymoon with
your bro just in case you play the
song's misinformation there's a pic of
the marriage certificate yeah soap will
never ask and you will never tell come
from half of the receipts that show you
shared the same name just in case you
claimed the song's misinformation here's
a pic of the marriage
[Music]
and all
future wet and consummated
only thing worse than ever is
terroristic
ated
[Applause]
will look like they're from the movie
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
here I know we said that we were gonna
have the Nancy Pelosi uh parody today
the She's So High parody but we had
problems with the track so there you go
even if it's not your style if you're
not hey you know what comment below are
you from that generation did you do the
Hot Topic were you a screamo kid Taking
Back Sunday is one of the few sort of
bands back then with musical Integrity
even if it's not your style it's a very
very difficult song to do
subject matter included you know whose
style it isn't
but I couldn't think of a better song to
drive home that Elon Omar had sex with
her biological brother
references available
and the certificate was also available
in the video
look at how bizarre this is where our
job involves doing a parody of Taking
Back Sunday about Ilan Omar marrying her
biological brother and just because we
know that we'll end up on the Nightly
News for inaccuracy we have to show Ilan
Omar's marriage certificate with her
biological brother
so don't doubt it actually I think he's
a half brother to be clear I don't want
to speak he's a half brother so so
you're saying just blood
on on the wedding night won't be blue
yet
it's gross these people are ruling your
country
AOC has eyes that you could buy at
Michael's and then you have Ilan Omar
with her brother and this guy I won them
at Dave and Busters
I want a zip a zip plane
all right we have a lot to talk about
today uh
Jordan Peterson actually I mean you know
what let's uh actually let's ask our
Booker see if we can get him on the show
here I know he's pretty busy but uh he's
a friend of mine and of course you've
seen mainstream Hollywood attack him uh
yeah Olivia Wilde who's one of the worst
people in the world and I think it's a
perfect Dynamic to see the mislabeling
that takes place at the hands of
mainstream media and thank God someone
like Jordan Peterson and we have a
platform we can fight back so we'll be
talking about that where he was praised
as or not praised he was vilified as the
in-cell king Olivia Wilde said that he
was praised by incels and that's not
true she's also the example Olivia Wilde
of a toxic woman and uh Jordan Peterson
also has been at the Forefront of speech
laws and I don't know if you know this
but an Irish teacher was arrested
because of using the wrong pronouns and
let me be really clear here
um this is something I've been warning
against for a long time not only being
from Canada and not only in the the
academic realm like Jordan Peterson Dr
Jordan Peterson warned about with Bill
c-16 but we've seen it happen in Canada
with comedy
we've seen it happen with bands and the
only thing standing between you and that
happening here in the United States is
the Constitution and the First Amendment
and the question I want to ask today of
you is and I think we asked ourselves
the wrong question well what is the left
doing what is the right doing no it's
what would the current Democratic party
do if left unfettered
do you think they'd have European
type speech loss do you think they'd
rather us be more like Canada
or more like the United States well
they've told you they've told you if
ex-president won they were moving to
Canada
take your pick of the Republican that
year so let's look at what that what
that actually means I think a lot of
people miss it it's not what are they
doing now what would they be doing if
they had absolute power uh and then
outside of Donald Trump I would also
like who do you think is the most hated
figure on the left I think maybe it
could be Jordan Peterson yeah by the
left you mean yeah most hated figure
what hate it on the left meaning they
they have their little hate group I
think Trump is the truth but yes maybe
that's it DeSantis is moving up the
chain I'd love to toss my hat in the
ring
In fairness yes yes that's that's a fair
point and by that I mean a little
liberal [ __ ] named hat yes how's your
war going
yeah that's the war yeah have you gotten
aid from other countries yet foreign
busy morning you said something messed
you up in that video do you wanna
what the movie what oh no Deliverance
yes we'll talk about that on mug club
today by the way you can subscribe we're
gonna do a full other hour and read the
things Tom likes on Mud Club which is
something that's actually being you you
know what it's gross and they want kids
to read it and we literally have to blur
out penises it's true and not by like
not a biological textbook no
servicing his penis and it seems rather
large and we can't you know yes I I know
that I I figured you would think that
and
the fastest man the quickest wit in the
west the fastest man in his feet he and
I will be in Houston September 17th at
the Smart Financial Center I guess in
Sugarland is technically but it's right
near Houston Dave Landau how are you
Ahoy good how about you man good morning
oh we got my little thing yeah I do I
got Joe Lewis on oh a big fan of the Joe
Louis Arena and by the way for people
out there sorry so many announcements uh
West Virginia Charleston we let you know
that it was canceled October 8th did a
family obligations uh conflicts that I I
couldn't fix scheduling wise but if you
send your ticket stub you'll get a
refund 50 of you if you send it to tips
at letterscredit.com we're actually
sending 50 people to Houston do it now
from West Virginia because we have to
announce that okay
let's move on from this first thing
is uh it's time to go to New York state
of crime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I love hip-hop but I also
realize how stupid they must feel when
they're doing their stabs if you listen
to that yeah it's he's just sitting
there and he's listening
that boy good
yeah sort of like a I guess the white
equivalent is Tim McGraw where he just
he made like five million dollars that
song with Nelly was just it's all in my
hand but he's just sitting here
okay girl I'm not loving you
yeah just wait another minute
well basically let's do another take uh
Tim Nate Dogg made everything better by
doing that and then everybody just can't
do that right like Warren G doesn't
exist without Nate Dog yeah and then Tim
McGraw just shouldn't exist well
period I I hope that he lives like he
was dying yes I do
track of
Jay-Z just the stab track all right I
got it
that boy good
Tribeca yeah
oh oh
thank you David
yeah taxi cabs yeah sandwiches what are
you talking about 10 words you get one
million dollars per word what is it game
show taxi uh Cash Cab that comedian's
really Ben what's his name Ben Bailey
he's great he's really fun he's really
funny me yeah yes mean if you see him in
roast you're like oh my God yeah I have
a big Ben Bailey fan uh Michael malis
got in Cash Cab once and I really want
to see that so did already Lang oh yeah
he got camera come on turn the cameras
off I don't want to bust my balls here
all right
let's let's sorry today's a weird day
life is now imitating art uh in New York
City uh as a bunch of uh hoodlums in New
York this is New York City and uh I warn
you it could be disturbing to many of
you no one gets killed so it's hilarious
this is crime in New York New York City
state of crime grand theft auto Edition
in broad daylight
I like how casual this guy is walking
away it's like bumper cars he's TR he's
chasing him down
he didn't move until the car might come
on the sidewalk yeah he's like yeah
whatever
otherwise it's just Tuesday
[Music]
I would have assumed that
right about this beginning of the chase
that he had a gun
I do love that he planned it with what
it looks like is that a Honda Accord
yeah watch there's gonna be some super
expensive car that no it looks like he
picked a beater and he's like I'm gonna
use this as a Ramen car yeah he's got a
Mercedes versus I can see a Honda CRV
yes one of those is gonna win that's an
SUV you're going to get fact checked on
it yeah yeah I'm sorry admonish him
admonish him the CRV is a crossover
because he needs to learn his automobile
was that was that a car that was a car
it was not an SUV it was a crossover SUV
I thought it was an SUV hey by the way
at the end of all that the happy endings
are the guy who jumped into the black oh
I guess it was a Mercedes well the
Mercedes was the hit car it was it was
like a Honda to me yeah I don't know the
point is he made off with twenty
thousand dollars in cash so not a bad
day of work there in New York City
that's 70 000 in vehicle damage
yes
oh I only got liability [ __ ]
that guy came out of nowhere why did
they have 20 grand in cash or is that
just what he said he took yeah this is
the mob come on yeah what happened oh I
had 20 grand in cash that's what he yeah
yeah why is there a whole like neatly
sick empty section in this duffel bag
next to the twenty thousand I don't know
I ain't seen it it's weird oh man you
said the limit was 20 grand yep well
anyway the good news is they'll catch
him and then they'll release him because
that's what happens in New York City
this has been Empire State of crime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that Stinger still makes me laugh
the snap track thing before you said it
was like that boy good oh yeah I feel
bad for anybody that owns a bodega yeah
New York City yeah especially if they're
Asian well yeah you just show up and
you're like so it's robbed yes ah yes
it's like the movie crashed so like they
told you to change the lock yeah it's
all like regarding Henry yeah
I remember when the Asians the South
Asian hate yeah remember when the Asians
were used as pawns by the left oh where
are they now still happening in New York
always still happening in the Bay Area I
thought they were used to slow down
trains no
as a matter of speaking I was gonna miss
the trip
[Laughter]
correct now
Jennifer Lawrence uh there's a lot we
need to get into here Jennifer Lawrence
uh has he's not has been having these
nightmares of Tucker Carlson sad it's
funny because I've had nightmares of
Jennifer Lawrence's pictures on the
cloud but she has been having nightmares
about Tucker Carlson she's now deciding
to go full left wing which you know she
was beloved by America Middle America
specifically for staying out of politics
or being a moderate and that'll tie into
Olivia Wilde attacking Jordan Peterson
think about this you have a film with
Harry Styles Olivia Wilde worst human
being that I can think of
who's not like you know like a terrorist
you know like she didn't kill six
million Jews I mean she's bad yeah yeah
okay it was there was a little bit of
hyperbole there I don't like Olivia
Wilde I think she's a bad person there
you go but then attacking Jordan
Peterson think of a film we have Chris
Pine you have Olivia Wilde you have
Harry Styles you have the other people
and they're using this platform to
attack Jordan Peterson who has dedicated
his life largely to serving others and
sure he has a platform now but this has
been incredibly respected and uh I would
say I would argue selfless
person in comparison to Olivia Wilde
Olivia Wilde what she does is only
self-serving Jordan Peterson has been
cited thousands upon thousands of times
yeah Jordan Peterson has helped count
including myself anyways let's start
with Jennifer Lawrence okay my question
to you is who do you think is more
likely to actually give Jennifer
Lawrence nightmares
um and I find it odd that it's Tucker
Carlson wouldn't you have guessed like
Harvey Weinstein's casting couch I don't
know it would be my assumption comment
below and uh hit the like button by the
way if you can because that helps with
the algorithms we found that out
recently with YouTube they're Shadow
Banning it brings us to Jennifer
Lawrence version of entertainment minute
[Music]
all right
Marley was dead to begin with so set it
up I think I already told you Jennifer
Lawrence uh said what are you looking at
tool man he keeps looking up is
something falling through the ceiling
you were pointing up is there going to
be propeller man coming in here yeah
you're reporting you didn't point out oh
I did yeah well I was just calling my
shot
I was saying Jennifer Lawrence
oh yeah the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's it
no I'm just saying this little boy in a
hospital somewhere that's like swing
away crowded
Swing Away
who'da thought who'd have thought the
planet that's 70 water could get you wet
aliens thanks Shyamalan now
I always we studied the dry parts
[Laughter]
look at this nope
we thought the Sudan about covered it no
we mastered space traveled but didn't
understand Lakes
I'm sorry but again it's a weird day
okay all right and for the Crowder bits
you have to cut that
oops when we cut this thing for crowded
bits on YouTube because you know people
have like a four minute attention span
now in a new interview uh obviously it's
hopeful sorry Jennifer Lawrence said
that she has recurring nightmares about
Tucker Carlson because she's such a
strong woman now uh she went on to
describe the rift that has come up with
her family because of politics these are
some quotes from her she said I just
worked so hard in the last five years to
forgive my dad and my family and try to
understand it's different the
information they are getting is
different their life is different I've
tried to get over it and I really can't
I can't I'm sorry I'm just unleashing
but I can't f with people who aren't
political anymore you live in the United
States of America you have to be
political it's too dire politics are
killing people I love it I'm I'm sorry
I'm just unleashing so you'll be
slightly more shrill and [ __ ] yeah and
by the way your movie Joy was not no
I would like you to be a passenger in
that Mercedes yes please hop in and
don't get out now here's the thing if
you don't remember this I mean this is
kind of weird because the website you
know we have all the references
available we used to write about
Jennifer Lawrence a lot of people liked
her just because she didn't seem she's
kind of fresh-faced you know it wasn't
as much of a Hollywood elitist they're
annuities right that as well she uh it's
a crowd pleaser she uh why not too many
freckles I don't care by the way
Jennifer Lawrence you might want to get
that mole checked yes they're out in the
sun too much if your booty has freckles
your boots are huge that's what the
doctor said so she did I remember she
she said this and I was like did I did I
dream this she said she was a little
Republican this is before Donald Trump
she said I grew up Republican my first
time voting I voted for John McCain I
was a little Republican she also
expressed some pro-gun sentiments I
remember in Rolling Stone 2012 where she
said I'm thinking of buying a house and
a big dog and a shotgun and she wanted
to talk about how she was raised with
guns here's here's my point before we
get on get into Olivia Wilde and I think
Olivia wild Jordan Peterson is the
perfect example of toxic femininity
versus I would argue flawed but a good
man a man trying to do good we always
assume that men are bad and women are
inherently virtuous that's not
necessarily true and it's not true in
Hollywood either but I think this is
important to to take take note of this
in Hollywood they are obsessed with
constantly telling you keep it real
right authentic I really think there's
an authenticity and I need to find
something authentic to identify with
with this character but everyone who
goes into Hollywood thing but no one's
really from Los Angeles that's the
ongoing joke if I may not know that but
allow me to present that to you they're
always from somewhere else so people
come from across the country people come
from across the world
I would imagine all different kinds of
viewpoints I would imagine all different
kinds of personal life experiences and
they all end up being elitist leftist
[ __ ] and [ __ ] let me put it that
way
how does that happen this is an industry
that sucks the life out of people and I
also want this is an industry where it's
the only place we're 100 divorce rate
exists it's the only place where yes
there is an ABS not the only place but I
was sure assume NAMBLA but a
disproportionate number of pedophiles
certainly if we look at sex crimes in
Hollywood sexual and you wonder these
people all have a meeting and decide
that they wanted to become this way or
do you get into this industry do you get
into that town and you compromise your
principles a little bit and then a
little bit and then a little bit and
you're so far away that you can't even
find the trail of breadcrumbs and and
find your way back and so instead you go
I don't want to acknowledge the failure
that my life has become sure Fame and
money but how many of them are miserable
uh let me let me aim my artillery at
Jordan Peterson because he actually is
authentic
because he actually is the same guy
everyone changes when they get in this
industry and if they want to understand
if you want to understand the disconnect
Jennifer Lawrence and the weinsteins of
the world or whoever it is who's what
anyone Paramount take your pick
whoever's watching we know they watch
um because then they get us flagged for
copyright this is why America hates you
you do not represent at all the very
broad views of the United States you are
so out of touch you don't understand
that everyone has to follow lockstep in
your industry and the only question that
remains is how much of it is just
I guess sort of guilt by a Association
sort of by osmosis where people become
really crappy how much of it is by
Design
and that's where you'll accuse people of
being conspiratorial if they tend to
believe the latter I think it's a little
bit of both yeah well the best case
scenario I mean you I mean really the
worst case scenario used to be you'd be
crap out of the bottom of the porn
industry but you don't even have that
anymore yeah
well worst case
no I mean honestly there's but you're
right did your parents apologize I mean
the problem is is at one point 10 years
ago she was saying who she really was
right she was raised by good people they
obviously did a good job with her she
ended up being a movie star she is a
good actress I'm not going to take that
away from her she that was authentically
her at one point now what she's saying
is simply to just she thinks that's what
fits in right she thinks that's what
America wants to hear right because
they're all clueless to the fact that
we're tired of it so she believes that
this is her taking a stand and going to
sell tickets even though if it doesn't
have the word marvel on it everything
seems to kind of fail yeah yeah good
point and this comes from a person or
Hunger Games literally shot exactly The
Hunger Games franchise which is all
about Elites in the dystopian World they
create where kids have a death match
she's now and they performed for drag
queens well they do that too right which
is it's all about opulence and it's all
about like the every the elites living
like that's you just basically described
like the Democrat party's wet dreams I
just walked by I haven't been in a
shopping mall in a long time and I was
there because it was a restaurant that
was good for there's a place where the
kids can go and I walked by I don't know
if it was I don't know if it was
Nordstroms or if it was Neiman Marcus it
was one of those department stores and I
saw I think it was Christian Dior uh
Natalie Portman and then I saw Charlize
Theron both people who are self-avoud
left us right who told you how to live
your lives and no doubt this photo shoot
cost millions of dollars right they
probably didn't have to go to Bermuda to
shoot it but they did and they're I'm
thinking hold on a second you want to
blame business owners who by the way are
considered the ultra wealthy if you have
a business that is basically grossing
five hundred thousand dollars a year
right meanwhile you live and I have no
problem with you making money but you
claim to be a socialist and you claim
that well hold on a second I make money
but this is a necessary evilness it's
what happens in this industry you there
is no requirement for you to sell what
is effectively toxic perfume
you want that extra few million dollars
and then you condemn the business owners
and the people who are generally pretty
wealthy but upper middle class
throughout the rest of the country you
are multi-millionaires and you've never
had to sign the front of a check you've
only signed the backs of them
that's why you're out of touch by the
way this is a live show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern uh we're here on
YouTube of course I ask you to hit the
like button that helps also Rumble
nothing would make me happier than if
you all just went over to Rumble that
would be fantastic where I'd never have
to broadcast here again and of course
mug Club we're doing a full other hour
today and reading
that's because Dave touched it before
you well I so
all right where did you get that sound
I sail I say that's awesome oh it's What
About Bob yeah yeah that was great great
film uh so let's get to Olivia Wilde
here and Jordan Jordan Peterson full
disclosure Jordan Peterson is a friend
of mine uh I know he's been on the show
quite a bit Yeah so obviously I'm biased
early on too yep well actually we had
him on before
he was famous in Canada knowing the
states really knew who he was and I was
following bill c-16 which is a speech
law basically in Canada and I'm really
glad that he's brought awareness here in
the United States I'm super glad for all
of his success so I'm just letting you
know that I do have a bias but all
references are available at ladder with
credit.com because this is a jumping off
point here I just ask that you go with
me I don't think we could have picked a
better example
or a better antagonist and protagonist
than awful though hot Olivia Wilde and
Jordan Peterson so
in an interview promoting a new movie uh
I have to read this Cliff don't worry
darling
director Olivia well because what I
really want to do is direct yes tell
more people what to do yes
I hate I'm sure and by the way I'm sure
she got that job by her qualifications
so well yeah director Olivia Wilde
revealed that the antagonist was based
on who she called quote an insane man
Jordan Peterson so she was talking about
I guess Chris Pine's character and
Olivia Wilde told Maggie Gyllenhaal oh I
shudder when I see Maggie Gyllenhaal one
ugly in Soul Olivia Wilde and one just
ugly well just off-putting yeah but we
can say that yes
so Olivia Wilde said we based that
character on this insane man Jordan
Peterson who is this pseudo-intellectual
hero to the incel community you know the
in cells so not only are the attacks
wrong
there and I hate it when the left uses
this argument where it doesn't apply
projection now let me be clear
projection is something that actually
exists and it's a psychology term
usually when dealing with repetitive
negative behavioral patterns but we're
talking about things within the realm
certainly within the boundaries the
guard rails of normalcy like if someone
says hey you're really selfish and you
don't think about anybody else and this
person says it to you over and over they
might be projecting however the left
will use it and say why are you so
opposed to pedophilia are you a
pedophile no it's because I want to kill
pedophiles
right execute Legally Legally sorry why
do you why do you feel this way about
monkey are you secretly gay that's not
projection projection is when you try
and apply your character traits or flaws
to somebody else so like when I tell
people I bet you have a huge penis well
that's
called deluded delusional yeah anyway go
on with them
so she attacks Jordan Peterson uh as as
an incel representative and as an insane
person and a pseudo-intellectual
okay uh
and by pseudo-intellectual you mean an
intellectual yes the most cited
Professor from University of Toronto
right yeah this is what they try and do
they try and wipe it away you know what
I've noticed just as another example I
was uh researching like best electric
cars so you can read the reviews of best
electric and for years years right now
Run a search plug in in California right
yeah exactly but no for years and years
go research this 2016 2017 2018 29. okay
it's almost invariably one of the Teslas
in every category right in the sedan
it's either one year might be the S one
year it might be you know the three and
then you have the X and you guess what
doesn't make the list not even the top
five in the last couple years I think
it's car you know what uh research team
you guys can bring this we can pull it
back up later I think if you pull up
like Car and Driver uh uh US World News
these are admins these are the places
that usually do the Roundup and reviews
yeah I was looking at it this week and I
I'm reading this going hold on a second
you're reviewing the number one electric
car and it might be the Kia one I have
no idea it gets half the range and it's
not as fast and it doesn't have the
track record and it's less reliable what
they try and do is the guy they praise
Elon Musk who they built up once he goes
off the reservation even a little bit
this is still the guy more responsible
for electric cars being in the public
eye than anyone in the history of
mankind they can't give him credit so
same thing with Jordan Peterson this is
a man who was the most sighted professor
at University of Toronto at least among
them top 50 most cited clinical
psychologists of all time yeah
Tesla bad you can see the crossover
point we can find that and let's bring
it up later I go 2016 17 18 19. and I
don't know when it crosses over at 20 or
21 but all of a sudden every Tesla sucks
okay so let's go on to this it's a
reliable source yeah at one point that's
a shame I know I know and it's the same
with Peter's it's just what it's what
they'll try and do of course with you
they'll say he's not they'll say he's
not funny that's the deal with Nick de
Paulo so they did with Norm Macdonald
once they thought it was conservative
well the second he passed away it was a
you know a me too thing and it's like
just shut up right just let a man pass
away who's a genius without bringing it
into it and with uh and I've read Jordan
Peterson's books it's like he he is an
intellectual yes and he has paid for it
physically mentally spiritually in every
way possible for what he's put out there
it's like what have you done besides
receive a ton of money Hollywood yeah
what did you put on the line well we'll
get to that because it's also allegedly
a
shooting motion picture so well of
course it is let's get to the first
claim did you see who directed it the
first claim here is Jordan Peterson is
uh the champion for the incels uh in
that term by the way if you don't know
it comes comes from the term involuntary
celibate there's a group of people out
there uh and by the way get laid hit the
like button that helps with the
algorithms if you're watching this right
now so uh wild describes in sales like
this she says they're basically
disenfranchised mostly white men who
believe they are entitled to sex from
women and they believe that Society has
now robbed them that the idea of
feminism is working against nature and
that we must be put back into the
correct place okay a couple of things I
don't even want to get into the in-cell
deal because she has no idea what she's
talking about that being said I'm not a
big fan I'm a fan of celibacy Chastity
until you're in you know marriage or at
least even if you're not a Christian a
long-term relationship I don't believe
it whoring yourself out if you're a man
or a woman is something that is
spiritually and emotionally fulfilling
long term so different there's celibacy
there's remaining chaste and then there
is in cell which is a group that she
also grossly misrepresents here's the
truth
Dr Jordan Peterson has little sympathy
if any at all for in cells and uh the
people who not only has he has he not
been a champion of theirs he's called
them to the mat and asked these people
in cells specifically
to look inwards to find their own
problems that's not your problem your
problem is why you can't find
the woman you want
and you you have to assume that's your
problem because otherwise you have to
assume that it's the women's problem and
really they're all wrong and you're
right so you're a young man and all the
women are rejecting you
who's got the problem
it's not all the women
that's a bad road to go down if all the
women are rejecting you it's you
who was the first white supremacist he
was talking to Larry yeah yeah
I just want to be clear so look look by
the way this is also what they try and
do is Muddy the waters and say you hate
women no no hate feminism hey despise
what women like Olivia Wilde stand for
and by the way that's not the same thing
as an incel they try and throw this all
under this wide umbrella a catch-all
term so they can vilify someone like Dr
Jordan Peterson right and they say that
they're entitled to sex from women right
this group of people who feels entitled
basically claiming ownership of women's
to see like oh that's what these people
want to do that's what people like
Jordan Peterson want to do they want to
oppress women and take away all of their
rights right so she's just trying to
throw him into this broad category
without having listened to any like you
just do a Google search just Google
search what he's saying say is that true
about Jordan Peterson and you'll see
this is also Rogan it's not some random
Backwater station in Canada it's the
person you tried to have banned from
Spotify yeah that guy it's right there
for your take why don't you read his
book yeah and this is also this also
helps to spell method acting that's
complete horseshit sure I understand
getting into character when people say
okay Heath Ledger his his problem was
actually driven by The Joker he never
broke character do you really think that
he was at the craft Services truck like
I'll have a ham sandwich no of course
not Olivia Wilde can't even read Jordan
Peterson's ball it's inspired by this
guy or like when people go for a ride
along for 15 minutes like now I know
exactly what it's like to being swapped
oh Heath's problem was an Olsen twin
with a purse full of Downers right
and it's the evil twin here's another
claim that Olivia Wilde makes and then I
want to paint a broader picture but the
the claim of course is Jordan Peterson
is a pseudo-intellectual we kind of
addressed this here's the truth it's
plain as day all references available at
later with crowder.com I want to make
sure that I read this correctly uh uh
Professor is it Professor how do you
pronounce this Emeritus Emeritus I
thought okay professor emeritus uh
psychology at the University of Toronto
okay we know that he's published more
than 100 scientific papers he's one of
the top 50 most cited clinical
psychologists of all time with over 18
almost 19
000 citations he's lectured at Harvard
at Oxford at Cambridge Chancellor at
Ralston college now good schools yes and
I want to make I want to be clear that
doesn't make somebody smart no right you
have plenty of people who've gone to
maybe a one maybe a Harvard maybe in
Oxford but the catalog of work this is
someone who was respected this is
someone who is praised this is someone
who is academically trusted for decades
until he decided that he wouldn't go
along with compelled speech and you
decided that he's a white supremacist
you decided to label them all right
that's what they did they said white
supremacist didn't stick they said alt
right didn't stick yeah and now it's in
cell leader didn't stick how about you
do your research Olivia Wilde I know I
know it's tough I know that using that
Mouse to just click add to cart it
stings just do a little you know method
act Daniel Day Lewis the [ __ ] so if also
was it him that made the video go viral
oh no it wasn't right it wasn't him that
gave himself the fame exactly it was
people who saw him and said this is a
problem we'll get to that person just
arrested in Ireland a teacher yeah we're
using the wrong pronouns they're coming
for you now if you want an actual
example of a pseudo-intellectual look no
further than Wild's boy toy yeah she was
cheating on her husband uh publicly
shaming him emasculating him uh Harry
Styles listen to him and I would say I'm
using the term loosely Harry Styles and
I say pseudo-intellectual yeah because
as he describes his own movie uh you'll
see that Chris Pine realizes oh the this
man's functionally [ __ ] I think
what's so amazing about the film is that
it's not
I don't think the intent
the intention of the film is to be
really entertaining and I think it's a
really entertaining uh film I think it's
you know my favorite thing about the
movie is like it feels like a like a
movie bruh it feels like a real like you
know go to the the
movie but you know you kind of the
reason why you go to watch something on
the big screen I think if you can
go away and think about it it just
punched in
have something to think about afterwards
I think oh If It Moves you whether it
upsets you or makes you feel happy or
makes you feel powerful or makes you
think is uh is what Art's for what
can't wait until his next Rock the vote
campaign you should look if you look
closely at Christopher Pine's neck you
can see it go from like relaxed like
yeah so relaxing he's just nuts even
though he's stressing he's about to make
a gay pirate porn yes yeah that is his
next flip a little disappointed because
I like Christmas movies
he's like it's like Kurt Cobain and
flood pants yeah he looks like he looks
like what River Phoenix died in yes
he's dead no River not Joaquin I know so
uh wrong brother for his part Jordan
Peterson did respond to uh Wild's
criticism he said now Pine has a
reputation as quite an attractive man so
it could be worse
does anyone want to say
I also hope that Chris Pine at least
does the sartorial Splendor of my very
formal public wardrobe justice as he
pillories me in the latest bit of
propaganda disseminated by the woke
self-righteous boars and Bullies who now
dominate Hollywood
and who insist on the production of such
tripe ah there you go I see little wordy
doc Peterson you could probably just
tighten it up you veered into a little
Dang Cook in the middle there
little all the self-righteous boars
Olivia well I take
Kermit the cook
doing my best
it's great now here's uh another truth
oh for the pseudo-intellectual doctor
Jordan Peterson and he also does a
doctor who doesn't make me call him
documents too which I like uh he also a
rare thing for a doctor like it's a
doctor and you're like shut up right
You're Gonna Save Jordan Peterson a
really good guy not always the best I
was like do you want me to call you a
doctor he's like so long as you don't
call me Elite for supper like oh geez
may I do the joking please
7 30 you were
can I say um so here's the here's the
beauty here and this brings us to this
dynamic between Olivia Wilde and Jordan
Peterson and then I want to talk about
feminism as a whole and why Olivia Wilde
is making the world a worse place for
you the woman the lady watching right
now Olivia Wilde is on a mission to
destroy what you want out of life Dr
Peterson has often described chaotic
Unfaithful histrionic women just like
Olivia Wilde while it's among
anti-social Behavior among adolescents
it's a well-documented field
so because people look at aggressive and
anti-social behavior in women and in men
and in women intends to take the
expression of innuendo gospel and
reputation destruction and in men it
tends to take the form of outright
physical aggression there's a whole
literature on that it's not a surprise
to anyone this has been known for for 30
years so what would be an unknown
unknown this is a good one here you have
an intimate relationship you've had it
for 10 years you trust your partner so
what does that mean you know where you
are
You Know Who You Are
and you have a pretty good idea of who
of where you're going
and then one day you'll find out that
your partner has been cheating on you
not with one person but with three
people and for the whole 10 years oh
geez well hypothetically that comes as a
shock
hypothetically hypothetically huh when
really he's talking about his friend
like Daryl yeah rice Daryl that's what
he ends with yeah hypothetically Daryl
was really upset but I had told he was
like Whoa man I saw them for nine years
yeah how can you have three Pool Boys
you don't even have a pool yes we're
like in Canada if you're lucky it's
above ground yes so just for reference
during filming Olivia Wilde cheated on
her fiance Jason Sudeikis please note
she has two kids and she was with him
for 10 years they have two kids together
and this comes from uh uh I think this
is from I don't know one of those gossip
regs I can tell you for a fact that Flo
Florence Pugh see seeing Olivia and
Harry all over each other on the sets
did not go down as well as as well as
Olivia was still with Jason when she
first hooked up with Harry I don't know
who's saying this I'm imagining that
some it was an Insider on the set oh it
was an Insider on the set what an awful
woman you know what else she did she
also lied about why Shia LaBeouf was
replaced calling him combative uh and
LaBeouf posted text messages showing
that she was lying now this is just sort
of the point is it's not he said she
said it's she said and he showed and
you're talking about the guy who
hijacked Shia LaBeouf's live stream that
he will not divide us like he showed me
his firm sued me it was funny too it was
pretty funny they lost in Epic fashion
but
the point is there's no love lost
between me and Shia LaBeouf but I like
to see the truth come out Olivia Wilde
is a lying manipulative selfish
[ __ ] and what do I mean by that I mean
someone who sleeps around uh and cheats
on the people with whom she's
verbally and physically signed a marital
contract and does it in a way that is so
public as to emasculate as to emasculate
her husband everyone was in feminists
are so quick to jump on the bandwagon
remember when she was served divorce
paper she was at some uh uh Jason
Sudeikis did in a very fun fashion yes
but everyone's like this is really
embarrassing and unprofessional you know
what's unprofessional cheating on your
husband on a film set while he brings
your children to your trailer and
everyone knows it and is uncomfortable
that's how women abuse men they don't
abuse men physically because they're
weaker and incapable of doing so they
abuse them through masculation through
manipulation through isolation and
everyone said this is so cruel Jason
Sudeikis I can't believe he would do
this because we have to assume that the
woman is correct and do you know who
that's worse for you you if you're an
honest woman that's not good you don't
want people automatically rushing to the
defense of someone like Olivia Wilde
because it makes all women look bad you
should want due process for women the
same way you want them for men whenever
you think of a man who's falsely accused
and you say believe all women or a man
who's falsely vilified just want you to
think of your dad or your brother or
your favorite uncle and think of his
life being destroyed because of a liar
like Olivia Wilde and by the way her
higher
higher something too feminism only works
if you grossly misrepresent history and
you act as though Society just treated
women like property and men just beat
their wives consequence free and tried
to keep them from voting and wanted them
barefoot and pregnant and so this was
the norm that's the only way that
feminism works because otherwise it's a
solution in search of a problem
in the film that she created I think we
have a trailer looks like one of those
revisionist history feminist fever
dreams
all of you wives
We Men We ask a lot
[Music]
we ask for strength
of food at home a house clean
and discretion Above All Else
oh no you have to smoke cigarettes at
home while your husband works boys and
their toys at least we know they're
getting work done
[Music]
welcome to the victory project we're all
here because we believe in the mission
what are we doing changing the world
what are we doing changing the world
that's right
all right look let me let me go with
this here for a second sorry I have a
stupid thing I got you let me hit the
what is
I have a button that lets them know that
I'm pissed
like we need a button for this yeah I
should have a button that says I'm not
pissed there you go um I caught it yeah
we're going for the table
okay let me hit you with some statistics
and there's a there was an interview I
did with a lady named Karen strong uh
and she's fantastic on this she's a
woman she specifically is is
unbelievably well read on the
suffragette movement and correcting some
of the lies that we believe some some of
which I believed I didn't know before
her that most women didn't want the
right to vote for example and I didn't
know why I think her I think her website
is ownyourshit.com so she's just one
example but there are a lot of people
out there who are women
who learn that all of this vilification
of men is based on some premises that
aren't so there was a lady who just uh
she just died she just committed a it
was assisted suicide I believe in Sweden
she was a lesbian feminist and uh
something was it Nora Vincent something
Vincent she did a a book you can find on
ABC where it's like black like me but
she's a lesbian feminist she was and she
actually went undercover as a man for I
believe 18 months and she left it and
she wrote the book and I think it should
be mandatory reading for people like
Olivia Wilde and really all women if you
want to better understand men this
Lesbian Family black like me no no it's
like black like me but like being a man
no I'm curious about reading it as well
there's also a clip maybe we can show it
later
um she was being interviewed by the
Asian reporter on ABC and she said yeah
actually men have it I I went into this
thinking that men had it easier they
don't
she didn't even just say both have it
hard in different ways she said men have
it harder
she said I was so grateful to go back to
being a woman because it felt like a
privilege this was a lesbian feminist
you have Cassie J who went on she did
that film red pill she started just so
you know the film and you see this time
after time after time when people
actually when women actually put
something on the line and try to learn
what it's like to be a man they go oh
it's very different than I thought
Olivia Wilde has not done that
statistically
it is undeniable that women
they spend far the awful old days as
they show in that that trailer women
spend less time on household chores now
it's Fallen by 44 since 1976. hey good
the evil oppression of men asking you to
help clean a house which is also yours
and he likes likely pays for hey good
you don't have to clean thanks Roomba
but here's the thing as their household
chores and duties have fallen down
because that's what oppresses women we
have study after study after study
here's one by the American economic
Association showing that women are more
unhappy than ever here's a quote the
lives of women in the United States have
improved over the past 35 years by many
objective measures yet we show that
measures of subjective well-being
indicate that women's happiness has
declined both absolutely here's the
thing both absolutely and relative to
men you know what else we have now is a
byproduct of feminine men won't get
married
you have an entire generation of men who
are refusing to get married last number
I heard I don't I'm going by wrote I
believe was 30 something percent it was
nearing 40 something percent and women
say I don't care I don't need a man till
they realize they're hitting that age
where that window is closing biology is
real despite what Cosmo tells you so
women are doing less work at home
they're doing less work at home they're
getting more Angry they're more unhappy
divorce rates are skyrocketing and men
don't want to marry you also because of
feminist divorce laws by the way things
like no fault one of Ronald Reagan's
biggest screw-ups it's not worth the
risk for men and then women
like I guarantee you Olivia Wilde thinks
that it's a problem with men maybe it's
a problem
that you you probably I'm assuming blew
your way to the top but certainly blew
your way out of your marriage in in a
public spectacle maybe you're an awful
person I know we're not supposed to
allow that possibility because you have
tits but maybe you're just a bad human
being and I don't know anything about
Jason Sudeikis maybe he's a bad human
being as well I don't know jury's still
out you definitely are
you absolutely are
and here's a big thing people don't know
there was a huge anti-suffrage movement
when people talk about the good old days
where women didn't want they didn't want
the right to vote a majority of women
didn't want the vote again you can go to
we have that reference there but Karen
strong has some stuff on that uh that if
you really want to do a deep dive here's
why
when people talk about oh how awful the
old days were and how great it is for
women now or how we it's good but we
still have a long way to go well you
mean a long way down the slope of
Happiness look behind you you were happy
you're there not because you were
property
no not because you were abused
you know the term whipping pose comes
from it's they used to whip people right
there's a post it was often used
for men who were found to be domestic
abusers yeah it was never okay and you
know where you know how else he got the
whipping post in some instances if they
found out that you were physically
abused as a man
because they wanted to embarrass you how
did you let that happen
abuse abuse across the board is a bad
thing but this idea that it's ever been
societally acceptable it's not true
feminism and the Olivia Wilds of the
world they're
a false solution in search of a problem
and they end up creating very real
problems so the reason that a huge
portion of women didn't want the right
to vote doesn't make sense to us right
if you think it was a bunch of guys
saying you can't [ __ ] shut up you're
right that's what they thought no what
it actually was men who voted they were
eligible for the draft they had to pay
taxes there was bucket Duty which is
mandatory voluntary uh firefighter
service there are a bunch of other
responsibilities that came along with
voting right women at that point in
history not understanding that they
would get all the benefits without any
of the accountability said oh we don't
want to do that I don't want to have to
run into a burning building I don't want
to get a rifle in my hand and have to
they said no no no no you're going to
get the vote
you're gonna get the vote you don't have
to do any of that
okay sign me up you need to understand
the historical context by the way this
idea that women didn't work that's not
true it's never been true nurses
teachers yes you'll think this is
offensive secretaries but do you know
why it's not because that's all they
were allowed to do
it's because women when they were
happier they were at home with their
children rather than raising their kids
by a nanny while cheating on their dad
on a movie set
back in the day they chose jobs that
allowed them to have the flexibility in
the kind of schedule that they could
spend with their children which what
is emotionally spiritually fulfilling
gratifying and yes particularly for a
woman biologically to be close with your
that's a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful thing and it's the kind of
beautiful thing that Olivia Wilde
discards
scars
well virtue signaling
that's why they picked those jobs here's
another uh example there's a
Scandinavian study
where the the countries with the highest
gender equality by the way in Social
programs
but show less parity in in stem fields
basically what happened is when women
this this I'm reading this quote here it
doesn't really make a lot of sense let
me break it down for you when women have
the choice
they often choose
to stay home
they would often choose jobs that are
more flexible
when women had the choice a true choice
and here's something else that I would
like to present to you women
um if you're watching and I know look
here's the thing too for all the in
cells out there not all women are Olivia
Wilde
but they're the ones in the public
Spotlight and they're the ones right
they're drumming the beat for the rest
of women across this country just like
Jennifer Lawrence thinks she's relating
to America by saying she's unleashing
her Fury against a republican family
Olivia Wilde thinks that she speaks for
you women you need to solve this problem
and let them know that they don't
you need to let them know that they do
not stand or speak
for you
and when we're talking about uh men and
women and choice I had a conversation
with a friend of mine
and
to be fair she's anti-feminist
um right on most issues and she said you
know it's the big life feminists they
want you to believe that you can do all
of it right that you can you can go and
work and also be at home with your kids
but you can he said you know you can't
it's just not possible right I agree
with her and it's kind of a lie but then
she went on to say and it just sucks
that women you know we're the only ones
who have to make this Choice okay let me
present something to you for one second
that must be nice
to have a choice it sucks that women are
the only one who have to make a choice
between being a stay-at-home mom or wife
which by the way is an important job and
is not to be denigrated or being a
working woman we can't do it all hey
comment below guys you overhand that
discussion being raised
that you have a choice
ever have that discussion remember when
you found out that you thought women
were attractive likely when you were
watching a hypersexualized Disney film
and you realize hey I like women does
anyone remember your dad or your mom
saying well if you want to have a good
wife and you want to have a family
someday you can be a working man or a
stay-at-home Pappy that never came up we
were never provided with a choice so
when you say women are the only ones who
have to make a choice it must be nice to
have that choice we don't have one
we will have to work
we'll have to Twill by the sweat of our
brow for the rest of our lives if we
want to have a and I'm not saying that
we shouldn't that's the agreement that
we've made
but it needs to be recognized
because for men to go out slay the
dragon go out hunt the wildebeest bring
it back home and be [ __ ] on
because woman doesn't have a choice to
have it all
well we don't have a choice
it must be nice to have a choice and by
the way women the only way you ever even
have that choice let's be clear
is with a good man
with a husband who allows you in other
words if you're a single mom your choice
is okay either you married a really rich
guy and divorced him or you're gonna
have to work and they'll be raised by a
nanny
you don't have a choice
of staying at home as a mom if no one's
providing for you or going no you're all
at that point you have to work have your
kids raised by any the only reason you
have a choice is if you're in a
relationship with a loving man who is
fulfilling his complementary role as a
masculine figure in your life and that
is not something to [ __ ] on the more you
do it the more unhappy you are going to
be the statistics reflected the
circumstances of society reflects it and
I certainly see it reflected when I look
in the face of Olivia Wilde some you
know what
ugly things happen in pretty houses
she's proof positive hit the like button
this has been entertainment minute
[Music]
oh shoot I forgot we have this whole
segment on the Irish thing all right
I just want to say
do you blame Olivia Wilde being able to
uh
excuse me how do you resist Harry Styles
in his career
come on the movie is like a real movie I
think you know maybe just tell him not
to talk during I think you're hot girls
like
I think you're hot like you're the kind
of one who's someone who I'd like to
have sex with but I haven't had sex with
yet and it's something I'd like to fix
and I did
not uh I like your breasts they're not
large but they're not like small they're
proportional they're tight probably
won't get saggy with that big blue vein
in it I won't do I don't like the vein
no it's not called river that I wish was
Droid like my aunt's diabetic leg
so if it's yeah yeah he's English right
yeah I didn't know Chris behind though I
just wanted does Chris Pine think he's
playing Jordan Peterson because I don't
think that was his motive well he's
certainly not dressing the part and it's
also not the time period right or what
he does I have no idea I because I
haven't heard anything about Chris Pine
saying that that's the role that's all I
wanted to break they don't think but I
don't I don't think it's his but I don't
think that was his motive right I think
that she's just saying that was his
motive right oh yeah so because she
wants to control men Invasion yeah
can you imagine if he's if if someone
asked Olivia but she's an actress and
Chris Pine uh happened to be the
director has tell us about this uh
character in Chris Pine goes I'll take
it I think what Olivia Wilde wants to
say is that her character is actually
drove people like oh you speak for her
yeah but they feel so comfortable doing
it with the guys the city just sits
there quiet and it's like let this
Syndrome guy talk yes part of this
that's kind of [ __ ] all right and
this brings us on what we're talking
about Jordan Peterson uh and I think
this might have been sent he might have
sent this to me but you know I've read
about it online because obviously coming
from Canada we know that speech laws
exist uh elsewhere and by that I mean
everywhere else
outside of the United States are the
only place where freedom of speech is
absolute yeah so uh it does help if you
you know comment below or hit the like
button again if you're watching this
segment I know it's separate from the
last segment uh did you know that did
you know that did you know that there is
no freedom of speech for example in a
place like Ireland and I don't mean kind
of I mean none
okay so September 5th uh Enoch Burke
teacher at Wilson's Hospital School in
Ireland was arrested and sent to prison
and then he was arrested for he was
arrested for violating a court order to
not teach or be present at the school
now I I need to sort of set the stage
here the the origin of that course in
court enforced suspension
um it came from refusing to address a
quote transitioning student and using
the term they Burke stated it is
insanity that I will be led from this
courtroom to a place of incarceration
but I will not give up my Christian
beliefs so this man was basically
stripped of his ability or is Enoch is
that a man or woman it doesn't matter
again we just ring the name you don't
see a picture I don't know the Irish
names when I was in Ireland the signs
were in Gaelic were they oh like this
just this is just reads like drunken
scribbles yeah where do you think it
came from
that's really all it was they're just
normal letters written by alcoholism
written with one hand and the other's
smacking the queen's English at 2 A.M
one's got a handful of potatoes
[Laughter]
I'm gonna write this sign welcome to
this province and I was born on a farm
and [ __ ] this is going to be good
for us so
you call yourself a what no
sit down hey stop doing stop changing
how many are served by the country by
the state oh it's right in scribbles I
guess I'll have to hit you twice because
you're are they yeah also because I got
that iron drunken Irish jaw so
um this is a person a teacher you have
to use the terms they and by the way
this is a transitioning student not even
fully transitioned so let's be clear
about this even if you don't agree with
me that this pronoun business has gotten
out of control can we all acknowledge
that you're gonna make a mistake if
someone is transitioning having people
on this show people who I like who are
transgender and I'm like is it they
sorry it's so hard to do
so just call me Dave you can just call
me down
now this is something that happens
across the globe and I want to get to
what could happen here in the United
States there's only one thing that
stands in the way of you and these
speech laws coming for you and your
politicians coming for you but this is
exactly this is precisely
the kind of law the kind of tyranny that
Jordan Peterson predicted and this is
the reason that he opposed bill c-16
which was a a bill that include
compelled speech largely pronouns in
case you've forgotten here's a time
machine you may or may not know I made
some videos criticizing bill c-16 and
it's and a number of its uh of the
policies that surrounding it and I think
the most egregious elements of the
policies are that it requires compelled
speech the uh the Ontario Human Rights
Commission explicitly states that
refusing to refer to a person by their
self-identified name and proper personal
pronoun which is the pronouns that I was
objecting to uh can be can be
interpreted as harassment and so that's
an ex that's explicitly defined in the
relevant policies so I think that's
appalling first of all because there
hasn't been a piece of legislation that
requires Canadians to utter a particular
form of address that has particular
ideological implications before and I
think that it's a line that we shouldn't
cross
Chris Pine looks different
pseudo-intellectual that sounds very
intellectual yeah well pseudo and by the
way this isn't just an isolated incident
here's some other examples all
references available a lot of credit.com
of people published simply for speech
the UK it's a guy jailed charged with
hate speech singing kung fu kung fu
fighting at a karaoke bar
funny in the UK in the UK oh yeah yeah
it's really bad in the UK and in Canada
a lot of people don't realize that's why
I'll never perform I'll never do a live
show in the UK or in Canada I won't go
you just go to jail oh sorry I will
never go Paddy Wagon sorry sorry English
fans you got to come Stateside there's a
recent trial in Finland and they
attempted to uh convict a Finnish MP in
a bishop try to convict them of hate
speech for citing citing what what is it
the Bible ah that document and so that's
where you have people can be criminally
charged right in these other countries
they can be arrested they can be hauled
off they can't do that in the United
States what the heavens is a bishop
doing with the Bible it's what
I don't know we've gone look behind you
there's the slippery slope I know
what's next makes no sense what's next
are they going to use the Old Testament
to set up a new like it's a preface to
the New Testament what what about book
three so they can arrest you jail you
charge you convict you in these other
countries you can't do that in the
United States
but often like when people say oh social
media it's a private business they can
do whatever they want the First
Amendment only applies to uh government
censoring your speech what about when
the government is working with
Facebook Google Twitter Youtube Spotify
what about when they're working with
them is that a private company if
they're doing the bidding of the
government or the CDC no no it isn't the
same thing here you can't be charged and
convicted criminally yet
but you can be Tried by the mob so we
have examples like a Kansas teacher was
suspended not arrested but suspended for
refusing to use preferred pronouns what
do you think is going to happen with the
teachers union the preferred pronouns
here look at their donations I believe
it's 99 to Democrat yeah but by the way
we're not going to keep you from saying
it we're just going to take away your
right to make a living right so that you
can provide for your family so go ahead
and say whatever you like but there are
consequences well yeah that's fine just
teach whatever the kid wants that's why
they're there yeah yeah yeah they're not
there to learn they're just there to
tell you what to say about them well
that's what we're gonna get into Tom
likes on the uh on mug Club I don't want
to see what lotto.com with the censor
this children's book
you all remember that right y'all
remember censoring the Cox and The
Berenstein Bears oh yeah they had what
this sex hammock is just right that's a
different building this is something
they're using to teach kids not porridge
yes
someone's been sleeping in my bed and
they're having an orgy now oh no still
in my bed yes so we have Bill c-16 in
Canada now the question this is the
question
not what is the left doing what would
they do if left completely unfettered a
good example this is when people say
they're moderate Muslims I understand
that
almost all of them live stateside
whenever you get a group of those who
are actually practicing observant
Muslims look at the laws of that country
is there any Islamic country that you
can point to
where you would want to live as a woman
as a gay person even as a as a straight
in these countries straight Brown male
who doesn't happen to be Muslim or as a
moderate Muslim right exactly yeah great
point you can't name one
so the question is what would the left
do what would the Democratic party do if
they had complete and absolute power you
can look to Canada you can look to
Australia you can look to places like
depending on who the pr the UK speech
loss you can look to Ireland so Canada
we have Bill c-16 is there something
comparable that Democrats if they had
their way would push here in this
country yes for example California
Senate Bill 219 it was designed to
prohibit the misgendering of trans
nursing home residents
[Laughter]
I feel like
so a few of those P they're too old for
that aren't they
well that's Betsy you want to chop off
your what
there are other examples of this too but
the point is if you look at state if you
look at State legislation Crips did not
punch them I mean the order leaves yeah
yeah just punch them in the wiener
they're roommates they're not going to
have it in a couple of weeks Dave that's
weird so if you look at the left and you
look what they believe in and also by
the way we can look to examples on for
example being suspended on Twitter for
saying hey monkey pox is largely a
disease that affects gay people boom
done gone you can look at the laws on on
on YouTube regarding misgender we had a
video banned because a transgender
person who threw a pencil case slash
homeless man's lunchbox that he stole
she stole sorry Acme I laughed because
he sorry she missed that was removed not
because of the felony taking place or
the victimization of the homeless man's
pencil case slash lunchbox but me
laughing at this man sorry beautiful
woman in heels and a Letterman's jacket
that's what they would get gotta watch
that video completely unfettered I think
you have to watch it on mug Club you
have to but it's freaking hilarious
do you want to pay for Grandma pasta
you might die if we Lop it off do it
anyway the point
for you Gerald
is this a kill shelter yeah
no we just put them in a cage and make
them comfortable Dr Kevorkian offering
researchers hey can you pull the plug
that wasn't an option no yeah but so yes
[Laughter]
the point is here if you're talking if
you're still at this point looking for
someone reasonable in Hollywood or on
the far left or even in the state
legislatures who have a d next to their
name
um it's about as elusive as
foreshadowing Bigfoot
Northern California
far from the hypodermic needles and
human fecal matter of San Francisco lies
a majestic Redwood forest Untouched by
civilized man it is here that people
travel the world over hoping to catch a
glimpse of The elusive Sasquatch
known by many names across the globe
Yeti wendigo here we know him simply as
Bigfoot why that's a curious racket
perhaps he got into a beehive maybe he
got his hands on some of that
methamphetamine on which the locals are
so Keen
who's that Dapper man is that General
Eisenhower no it's Bigfoot himself
he found the manscaped lawnmower that's
right the lawnmower groomer from
manscape it features a premium 7000 RPM
Motor with quiet stroke technology it's
also waterproof from the future and can
take on your toughest coarsest hair
especially where it matters most like
those sensitive unmentionable areas tell
me handsome friend you think that
Contraption could shave one of those San
Francisco beatnik grogs will it just
share an entire Sasquatch didn't it
oh Bigfoot that's for another day my
friend for another day
[Music]
you should have seen the commercial that
did not make hair for manscaped by the
way you get to hear about commercials
that don't make air when you go to our
live shows
I had that whole one about Walther yeah
and the world dictator who won't be
mentioned right uh but man I will tell
you this I actually so when I had the
surgery I had to shave everything
and the light on this and there's a
light on the on the it makes a huge
difference it's not flattering don't get
me wrong you see everything it's raking
across the surface you're like what do I
what do I have with Leprosy but it's
very effective and I will say it doesn't
cut I had to shave my chest for a while
yeah and I will say this the one thing
since the only part of my body is gonna
sound weird
my pits I use the Clippers on my pits
you know why because I had to do it
after surgery and I realized it felt so
much better there wasn't that friction
really when I jog
that's you jog huh it's more comfortable
no I don't I shaved him once to get this
uh mirror dry stuff yeah and the hair
never really grew back all this good for
you well it's because you're clogging it
with aluminum yeah probably by the way
you should stop rubbing a hot mocha pot
under your armpit I don't mind I don't
care if it kills me early
so you can use your discount code uh
Crowder 20. they have a bunch of
products the one I really like and uses
the manscape lawnmower 4.0 it's uh it
really works as a light on there if you
use the promo code Crowder 20 you get 20
off 20 off and free shipping
manscapes.com uh they're good they have
the balls ironically to sponsor this
show and of course you can also shave
you know your uh to face
I I have a I have a separate one right
he just needs to talk through a
soundboard Casey it's so much better
than when he actually speaks
I have to go beat yakuza's ass we're
gonna read things Tom's likes things Tom
likes on uh on please hit the like
button that helps with the algorithm
leave a comment thanks Tom on on Mud
Club we've got another 45 minutes to go
let's do this
foreign